hey, youtubers. its Charlie
this is going to be my agents of shield episode 18 video
The Frenemy of My Enemy
this week was all about shifting alliances
so i am expecting versions of this to happen
in captain America civil war
this episode took that to the logical next step
you know, alliances changing many, many, many times
you could also consider a minor crossover
with age of ultron
but only because of a passing comment
in one of those hydra scenes
so be careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet
ill actually start with that
the only real point of crossover in the episode was when they
referred to baron von strucker
and doctor list being obsessed
like crazy obsessed with powered people
as we know baron von strucker, using loki's staff
to experiment on people
to try and create powered people
slightly different from what's going on with the inhumans
but Coulson and his team members
don't know anything about that
based on the winter soldier post credit scene
il would even go as far to say, that von strucker
is keeping his experiments a secret from the rest of hydra
so even though doctor list
found a way to track Gordon, to track the teleporter
he's still probably no idea what baron von struker
is doing with quick silver and scarlet witch
so here we go op 5 WTF moments starting with number 5
fitz shakes the tail and joins team Coulson
I think we all expected this after the last episode
so it wasn't a huge surprise, but it was nice to see
fitz go on the run
you know be a bit of a secret agent
we don't get a lot of opportunities to see James bond fitz
the next step up would be like par core fitz
the real action for his character was dealing with the alliance they had to make with ward
the person how caused him all these mental problems
that's only going to get worse now to. because Coulson turned himself in to, I suppose infiltrate the real shield.
so fitz is left with Hunter, ward and agent 33. so he's properly even less happy hen he was before
on to number 4
Coulson makes a deal with ward to get Intel on hydra.
if it was a little confusing on why he had to make the deal with ward
its because he needed information on the inhumans
from hydra that only ward could get
so he could find where Gordon took skye
that Mexican restaurant that they had their scene in.
was one of my favourite agents of shield sets in recent memory
its just so funny how they meet in the most mundane places
like they might go to some hole in the wall eventually, and have some shwama over some really tense meeting
don't you think it was interesting to that death lock asked agent 33 if she had a speak mask lying around
as much as he is full on death lock no he still thinks about his appearance like he still wants to look like a normal human
then we have that big Tahiti call out, that was a lot of fun.
so what Coulson was talking about, the Tahiti protocol is just the mind wipe
nothing else
but when he says Tahiti though your mind kind of goes to Kree blood
so like are they going t kill him does he have to die
and then resurrect him
no, really its just what they did to Coulson after they resurrected him
when he had that giant machine poking around in his open skull
that does not look like fun, so you can not fault ward for being a bit apprehensive
Coulson does try to appeal to humanity in him
but their both kind of playing each other
Coulson's like
I give you my word as the director of shield.
but surprise surprise, he's not the director of shield anymore
and ward is properly lying through his teeth to
that just goes back to the Frenemy of My Enemy line, they both know they can not trust each other
but they have a bigger common enemy, so their working together temporally
that's why I think ward was so willing to help Coulson at that big
firefight at the end
and he has a bigger goal that he's trying to achieve anyway
so its in his best interests to keep Coulson alive
it does make you wonder, if there's going to be some sort of redemption
for his character at a certain point
really I don't care I think he's a lot of fun the way he is right now, being totally bad.
the whole potted plant, house of agent 33 was a little surreal
we will end up seeing what that end up looking like they may have some twisted romance
think joker, Harley Quinn kind of thing
on to number 3
Skye goes on a daddy daughter date with her father
I think we all knew he was going to loose his mind at a certain point
we were just sort of waiting for the hat to drop
was it going to be the thugs that bumped her on the street
was it going to be the hydra agents
I though the minute he saw the pastry shop, had been replaced with a bank, that was going to be it
once he found out what was really going on, what the inhumans planned was to really do was dump him off
he did get pissed but he still wanted to save Skye
he jumped into the portal with Gordon and Skye
so il be interested to see what they do, how that changes the dynamic back at the inhumans base
back at the after life, or whatever they want to call it
because they are going to want to rescue Lincoln
the whole side trip was a nice call back to the comics
daisy Johnson is the quake character, that who Skye is basically, the  comic book character
so, she says her name out loud to see what it sounds like
she found out her first name was really daisy and now she found out what her last name was
what I would like to see in a future season when like all the shit dies down
she is forced to go undercover and as a point of comedy she uses the secrete name daisy Johnson.
Technically  daisy Johnson does not exist in the real world, there's no birth certificate or any thing like that.
so she could use it as an alias
on to number 2
Coulson and ward use bochie to infiltrate hydra
this is going to be the real test
seeing weather or not his conditioning holds up
the end of the episode made it seem like he turned on them again
like he broke his programing
agents of shield is all about shocking twits
so I wouldn't be surprised if he is still conditioned and that this is all an act
like he's acting for hydra, for the benefit of hydra
that was a really awesome evil grin on his face though
did anyone else see the star wars Easter egg
whenever they were on the airplane
and he's like I offer you death lock
wait their giving him to him
its like when Luke skywalker offered C3PO and R2D2
to Jabba in his palace just to ingratiate himself to him
since they captured death lock and Lincoln at the end of the episode
ill be interested to see if they really do upgrade his compliance software.
there really only about 4 episode left, there will be a couple more shocking twists
and I am still expecting a really crazy big villain reveal, like Whitehall to step out of the shadows
something even bigger that we haven't seen yet, something unexpected
and finally my number 1 WTF moment
Coulson doubles back and turns himself into the real shield
so if this seems confusing just remember the title of the episode The Frenemy of My Enemy
so now i think that Coulson thinks that real shield is less of an enemy then hydra is.
so he's going to ally with them temporally without them knowing it.
I don't think he cares a whole lot about Lincoln, he doesn't know a whole lot about him right now
but I think he will try and save him too. because he's trying to save death lock
he is going to get the biggest slap in the face from may though whenever he gets back
she saw him with ward so she properly thinks he's turned
its really hard to tell what's going on inside her head
I don't think that she has completely turned on Coulson, but it a very
captain America civil war, where its like the truth matters its not about sides
I think Coulson turned himself in as a measure of last resort though
like he needs resources that real shield has access to, so he needs to back to the base
ward was like, we are out manned out gunned, we just can not do it by ourselves. we need more help
so ether Coulson is going to try and turn more people inside real shield to help him out
or he's going to try and make a bargain with real shield like he did with ward
so they did a really good job at teeing all the running plots together, thematically with the title of the episode
here my big question for you guys
what do you think that Coulson is going to try to do to get death lock back?
and what do you think the inhumans are going to try to do to get Lincoln back?
what i am hoping is that all of these different forces, converge on doctor list, on hydra
right now he seems like the likely candidate for big bad
that is unless Whitehall resurfaces
which is totally possible
but right now, doctor list is like the biggest hydra person that isn't bachie
this whole system of shifting alliances is why I think shield works so well this week
it does a really good job of telling these types of stories
that's why it was able to cross over with captain America winter soldier is a much bigger way
and next year when we get to captain America civil war
there will be a much deeper integration with agents of shield
beyond the minor points of crossover that I already mentioned
there wasn't a whole lot of Easter eggs in the episode, there was a hulk shout out
but I don't consider it much of an Easter gegg
but if you did see anything, specific like any logos like that in the back ground, let me know
just a reminder in related news, i am working on a daredevil videos, and an arrow/ flash Q and A
for this week, so I will try and get that up by Saturday
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I am going to do an avengers age of ultron Q and A to.
but i am going to wait until after my spoiler review next week
in case you missed it I did a non spoiler review for age of ultron
click here to watch it
and click here for all my other marvels agents of shield videos
ok everybody lets high five, I will see you guys tonight.